thank you to the academy thank you to
everyone involved in the making of
whiplash and I am grateful every day
for the most remarkable person I know my
wife the wonderful Michelle Schumacher
I'm grateful for your love your kindness
your wisdom your sacrifice
and your patience
which brings me to the above average
children even though I may try the
patients more Joe and Olivia you are
extraordinary
human beings smart funny kind loving
people and that's because you are a
reflection of your mother and if I may
call your mom call your dad if you're
lucky enough to have a parent or two
alive on this planet
call them don't text don't email call
them on the phone tell them you love
them and thank them and listen to them
for as long as they want to talk to you
thank you thank you Mom and Dad